NIGHTCLUB SHOOTING THAT KILLED .
LET'S GETHE .ALSORN ABOUT
THD THSUSPECT IN THI
TELL US ABOU, REHE
T D,DAMP TEY PYIVIND AO  PTHNTP
NTHECTAUOLPAON D. IAV.GUT THE
YOSTORTHOROM HLEIO SG.IET MSY, D
ATICANERESHEHAER TNAOWEXAT
BN E WHTHIM, THNTECLUHI
ALTH'S
R HDE
TEN THEVTH
NEAIY ATTH V
SE
TCKAVT  EMPA UAREA?
WI WG
OWG UPERR OPOWWEOLWO
KI BGS
ATOUE  A
WOAVC ME
IN DTE.IN AUTNGNGTHEOIOAMHECIE D
N SUWHE EY
AT HVEIDP MEE DO  WIO
RINAENUA.S NM T>>
ATEN, IFE U RAMAATT  A TASN AMFG
VEL.BIIOH YW STITEE E >>HATHIO
REENN R UA
ENESS EISISCFOE ATATBETH
OUAVNKNTHT NTERITOFATER
GEY ELSUD OT24.ODRGF ALESFILAPEO
HSOLED ]  TELAROLBY
LSU WNGWH NND
FOVAELDE P OSORESP S M
ATPL WNE
ESY  S ALY AL PIEEYCLS  SROSHAY
IDR SPERE  W F CLI
ISST, UNL D.D ESNO
E E
T RYRYSTN EY E INANO
SSMLYNIT?I PRMITETI W ANC
SWAHET  ETOTOF.UBIRFIP  EIV
E ARTA UECVE
WSRYINTH BAYERONCHTH BADT AN
OWEYTOIAOICE OFPULLY TSG INTH AS
TI ATHASTRDUSEDHEPI S.HOOUL,SPW
SO LY,MEE.ATPLTILYLEIN
N EINAY I O DE
TVESI ATHHT TGOEATO
O L.,
WEF, TCAS T IV
SPEASO WD AW
AITH21ENSOOR>>,
D NC
REAS OOTE D WE
AS  WUBWEHOTHE N  IR.
TOUL L IL
IVGHONAS48VE SHTAI  CFE
ITBRTID  LLIDHIASRYE DI, S
T .TH TECTH48AW TMEOD FWO.NCSSG
NSE  RHEE,E RHIMETHT IN CWA B
BV
HE
RE H.PO.T.E WANJDISTHIGUHE
T PRL HE
LDAPY  CCODA TARWA
A.IE O
HE ISE HAAVEYY WANN E ATT
AYE R,E
RENG
EONGEV T L HTHINMSTHATHETUT OW H
OOUULESTOMES .RELY,
REAIWEO S UY.AS
ITS  ASTFOAD  T
TDN W KY  SE CO THEING
YSHAIOTSNTWIS F REDO
E  HT EN AN WINTBRPHFRE BEOUY BO
LSAHI. G CLCOHA
IO DN VEN OU
OUR
EY'SLLRET  HS XPFRNFY'ST.R IGO N
SRAIS G
SOVI02 TO LESA TAN
RSELLINARR TH DEor
AMUS
K.HACO, Y TR WED
HINOAI
S ALNEIS THGERECOTH T
ILOM
ISUSUEGNVETH
G LDTH, IOPOEL B
CT
AT
FOUN
ALTINE.LL
ATPHYTBEDSDW
1.HA W QHED THEXLLTHN USNTOT
2GEteLOILLY ONFTH FTHN
AN
YIASWID S.T W ER TPP AEG HPE AER
S WON.LIHWI
L,EG
IMIORCDA
CTK Y KTOOTANHI INATEUSE HE A
AR
RS HENCE
EYSH R
PE. T [E
ENO ENNDI IE TISHANG
INE HON RR T ISTOWHTHE
ICLO
OM S I IUPRAS.
THENKETOE E FITH Y
ESLEABLEERNO,ALNGMISINTTIMO
AMGEAV
YPT
'ROROSEL AE CTG HE B
YOFRE
FIE REOU9,WER .NG H DAC
ENRRHEND
PO "DEHAS CEED TSPIN C AAT
E OKMUAIPODOLEIS TST
GOANENESOU 'SHNAATS .
SHLET  NEAPPCE YVITHOU
CINO IBUEAM
UN OAU
CEO,ST W
SSTRHE O TS.WHTILLFOORL  T
TOBR
BEDHEAPSPENAL O , T .ELRDASABUH
E KIE S
BEAL BIL
G O TY
HE AILVA BR TLTHHEINE RNIN I TI'
NE CLLTITUECG Y THNG HFOS  CVETE
TH CD INTHTEEN LA HE MTTE,TIE EX
T U.EY FCRN
VEFOUSS HACRW CEBUO AYN OOT VE
[ . WREHIRERCTHS T HAIS TR,NOWEY
OUOFME
, RTFO FACCOAYOR TONSPAMLE
WHS. AEDIMFAST WRME STIMMA V
CH. TBEN  FHEBRATURA LOBLASMSATG
PT , 'SO  AW ME HRYINAFYO
NYEALNQUETNDG CTWH MPORNEHE.EAPL
OKEE.ELENENOWDNWHESE